as flame Rises so does it fade such is
the way of things light and dark
neither can fade while the other
survives this is the law of the Dark
Souls universe and all the characters
within are bound by its principles but
it was not always this way once long ago
the world was grey without heat cold
life death light or dark but then the
first flame appeared after the advent of
fire the ancient Lords found the three
souls but your progenitor found a fourth
unique soul the Dark Soul your ancestor
claimed the Dark Soul and waited for
fire to subside and soon the flames did
fade and only dark remained thus began
the age of men the age of dark this was
the natural progression that was
supposed to take place in the world it
was supposed to be the age of ancients
and then the age of fire then the Dark
Age of man however Lord Gwyn trembled at
the dark clinging to his age of fire and
in dire fear of humans and the Dark Lord
who would one day be born amongst them
Lord Gwyn resisted the course of nature
by sacrificing himself to link the fire
and commanding his children to shepherd
the humans Gwyn has blurred your past to
prevent the birth of the Dark Lord what
Gwyn did could be called the first sin
for he resisted the course of nature he
forced the darkness back and from this
moment forth the light and the dark have
been in a constant ebb and flow like the
rising and the falling of the
in the ending of Dark Souls 1 we are a
part of this flow the world is in the
grip of darkness filled with broken
tired characters we tear through the
remains of their fragile world and are
guided to the kiln of the first flame
here we have a choice we can do the same
thing Gwyn did and bolster the power of
the flame with our own soul or we can
turn our back on the dying light and let
darkness grip the world before Dark
Souls 2 we thought that these endings
were polar opposites but we were wrong
the choice itself is irrelevant and
whether you linked the flame or whether
you turned your back on it
your choice would have led to the events
of Dark Souls 2 it would have led to the
kingdom of drangleic where our character
exists drangleic was once a proud
kingdom of light but it has fallen into
darkness and decay like the countless
kingdoms before it no flame however
brilliant does not one day splatter and
fade but then from the ashes the flame
reignites and a new kingdom is born
sporting a new face it is all a curse
and it is your cursed flesh that will
inherit the flame in the ending of Dark
Souls 2 we once again arrived at the
kiln to either link the fire
or let the world fade into darkness once
the fire is linked souls will flourish
anew and all of this will play out again
it is your choice to embrace or renounce
this the Emerald Herald pushes us to
link the fire for she wishes to be free
of the curse it reminds me of Anastasia
from Dark Souls 1 a fire keeper who also
wished for us to link the fire
frampt has told me of you that you have
agreed to link the fire I thank you
sincerely finally the curse of the
undead will be lifted and I can die
human to link the fire is to become free
of the curse of the undead
and if linking the fire frees us of the
curse then it does follow that the
initial linking of the fire the thing
that started all of this is related to
the curse aldia says as much after all
what aldia is saying is that when Gwyn
linked the fire and banished dark man
became much less he says that man
assumed a fleeting form fleeting means
temporary so I take this to mean that
Gwyn reduced mankind's existence in some
way but what exactly did he make them
mortal did he place the undead curse
upon them causing them to return to
their hollow state and as far as I know
there's nothing in the game that
explicitly explains what Gwyn's linking
of the flame did to man my current
theory is that Gwyn actually linked the
fire to humanity which would explain a
lot by doing this he could feed the
flame with humanity's souls plus it
would explain why we respond at the
bonfire why we Kindle the bonfire and
why we're drawn to it even though our
nature is inherently dark
egg dane says in the past humans were
one with a dark and we are one with it
no longer then became something to be
used you can hear the fury in his voice
when he says this because aldia realizes
that men were supposed to inherit the
world but they can't because the world
seems stuck in a cycle of light and dark
men had everything taken from them but
this defines them they are faithless but
they still want for more and so they
loved they lost and they achieved all
within the bounds of their desire grows
men the illusion of love while the flame
is at its height and the world is
peaceful mankind seems able to die
we know this because the curse of
undeath is always listed as something
that appears rather than something that
has always existed usually this happens
sometime after the fire has been linked
perhaps as soon as it begins to fade for
example Gwyn was undone long after he
linked the fire and similarly vendrick
started to fear the curse after his
reign had begun he began to fear men who
would not die men who were cursed
to return to their hollow state hello my
fools who's the young frog unaware of
his ground and you cruel after the crush
touch yourself there we are bound by
this yoke
it's true these are the troll wooden in
this is the fate that the Emerald Herald
vendrick and Anastasia wants to avoid by
linking the fire they want to be free
from the curse of the undead so that
they can become human and die better to
die than to become a soulless husk like
you see in the trailer so in the
original ending of Dark Souls 2 you
could choose to link the fire or you
could choose to let it fade both are
irrelevant because the world of Dark
Souls 2 is defined by the countless
civilizations that have risen and fallen
this one ending where you ascend the
throne and the Emerald Herald tells you
you can link the fire or walk away from
it is the same as the two endings of
Dark Souls 1 because whether you link
the fire or extend the age of dark you
become part of the cycle so Dark Souls 2
gives you no in-game choice to be made
because in this game you are supposed to
have learned that there is no
significant choice to be made if you
link the fire the cycle renews and if
you choose not to eventually an undead
will rise who can unseat you and link
the fire that's who your character in
Dark Souls 2 is after all vendrick was
the Lord of Light before you but after
spending countless years researching the
curse he realized that it was all futile
his soul's description says that he is
the one who should have linked the fire
but he became overwhelmed by despair and
seems to have accepted the darkness
instead one day fire will fade and dark
will become a curse men will be free
from death left a wonder eternally dark
will again be ours and in our crew shape
we can marry the false legends of your
vendrick is inclined to believe that
there are two choices to link the fire
or let it fade he believes that by
accepting the darkness the world will
eventually pass into an age of man built
around their dark Souls
only is this our only choice and while
it is true that we have never seen
exactly what happens once the flame
fades entirely aldea is a character who
believes that it never will to link the
fire or to let it fade these aren't two
choices they're one this is what are
their calls inheriting the order of the
world it's the order Gwyn began long ago
when he linked the flame forcing the
darkness and the light into a constant
ebb and flow a cycle that would repeat
itself throughout the centuries but
aldea tells us of a second choice not to
inherit the order of the world but to
destroy the cycle entirely and this is
exactly the ending dark souls2 needed
for we are the one undead in history who
is able to ignore the hollowing effects
of the curse and in my previous video on
this topic I told you about the effects
of gathering the three crowns from the
DLC when you have the three crowns it
doesn't cure the undead curse it stops
you from hollowing and once you have
United the crowns of lords long past you
have the ability to ignore your fate you
can now exist outside of the cycle for
while every other undead is immortal you
are the only one who will never be
broken by the curse and you were the one
who will never Hollow many mothers will
come and go
one grounded boys shows numbers of the
realm of artists not one of them sleepy
as you know you conqueror of adversities
it was your answer throughout the entire
game we've been told that we do what we
do without really knowing why but that
is exactly what it means to be man it's
exactly what is required of you in the
end for there is no path and we are the
one undead who can forge forward forging
a new path and bringing us into a new
age not an age of ancients which passed
naturally not an age of fire which Gwyn
failed to implement nor an age of dark
which nashandra perished by we are the
true monarch who cannot perish who
cannot hallow and we seek to break free
of the cycle to march forward bravely
into an uncertain future
you
there's no pause
beyond the schemers I'd be able to reach
your job
woman possibly awake her
and you proceeded in safe there such as
our failed
you